we're going to take a turn to what you
need to know
some of the copy-pasting snarky
commenting from tuesday that leads the
news on wednesday chris harris jr after
a protracted negotiation that turned
acrimonious at times the broncos and
harris settled on a one-year adjustment
to his contract basically money for
nothing from 8.8 million to 12.05
million with no strings attached other
than he'll show up which is what he
hadn't done and it proves that you do
have leverage if you stay away from off
season workouts sometimes you can get
the team to do something and chris i was
impressed that the broncos decided to
give him another 3.25 million dollars
with no extra years on his contract he
still gets to be a free agent next year
this is a great outcome for him and i i
think it shows growth and maturity on
the part of john elway because john
elway's habit has been win every
negotiation even if you crush the other
side i think it's refreshing and it's a
good message to the team that he's taken
care of chris harris jr who had a below
market contract for years yeah exactly
right it looks good on both sides it
really does i mean you know first off
hey chris harris jr he did things the
right way in this situation yes he
stayed away but he he was very open with
the media talking about the situation
what he was asking for talking about how
he wanted to stay in denver and how
special it was to play for the broncos
so that looks good from his aspect and
now he gets a little sweetener on top of
things for acting appropriately so we
always like to see that right instead of
like the squeaky wheel always getting
oiled and then yeah with john elway i
think this was a smart move i mean of
course it helped chris harris junior's
leverage i think that it's such a big
year for the denver broncos in general
they have a true need at the position if
chris harris jr left and uh they would
be a little you know stuck in a tough
spot as far as the cornerback position
is concerned but the biggest thing i
think just to piggyback off of what you
said mike i mean this goes a long way in
the locker room to show guys hey you're
a team guy you do things the right way
you know you don't make a make a fool
out of us in the media when things
aren't quite going your way and we can
be
respectful and come up with a deal that
works for all of us so from that
standpoint it all looked good
and it's clear that something that stuck
in harris's craw the fact that kareem
jackson stranger to the organization
signs a three-year 33 million contract
with 12 million in cash flow this year
chris because chris harris now has
12.05 million in cash flow that was
something he wanted and he said so he
told mike cliffs of nine news in denver
i wanted to be the number one paid
cornerback on this team nothing against
kareem jackson but i wanted to be number
one and now he vows to hit the market
next year and be the top paid corner in
the nfl when you look at the market
hasn't moved at all since josh norman in
2016 maybe harris has a chance to
surpass josh
norman next year no yeah i mean i don't
think he does i think he has a chance to
probably stay around the same type of
average salary that he's gonna get this
year you know 12 12.5 maybe 13 million
dollars again you know this is a guy
that's played eight years in the nfl at
the cornerback position so it's starting
to go downhill a little bit he's still
really good don't get me wrong and he
certainly deserved to be paid like the
highest paid corner uh on the denver
broncos because he is the best corner on
the denver broncos he's putting the most
work there and yes karim jackson who's a
really good player is a newbie to the
team so i understand that just from you
know pure locker room uh just what you
know what do i want to say pecking order
that's where it makes sense there so
yeah i expect chris harris jr to hit the
free open market next year but i don't
know if he's ever going to compete with
those top top dollars mike i'd have a
hard time believing that one
well he got more money and he still has
the chance to chase even more money next
year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports